le projet de loi constitutionnel
renforce l'efficacité de la procédure
législative et l'effectivité du contrôle
parlementaire sur ce point le
gouvernement a pris en compte
l'opposition formulée par les présidents
des groupes parlementaires à l'idée d'un
contingentement des amendements cette
disposition qui avait été envisagé a
donc été retiré mais les présidents des
assemblées ont convenu qu'il était
nécessaire de limiter les amendements
sans portée normative sans lien direct
avec le texte ou qui ne serait pas du
domaine de la loi
le projet de loi constitutionnelle
prévoit donc une disposition en la
matière sans revenir sur la réforme de
2008 qui a défini un équilibre entre une
semaine de contrôle une semaine
d'initiative législative parlementaire
et deux semaines d'initiative
législative gouvernementale
les projets de textes les plus
importants ou les plus urgents pourront
bénéficier d'une inscription prioritaire
à l'ordre du jour par ailleurs la
procédure sera accélérée après la
commission mixte paritaire
en cas d'échec de la commission mixte
paritaire même si la nouvelle lecture au
sénat sera maintenu enfin sur le modèle
de ce qui se pratique au sénat la
discussion en séance pourra être
focalisé sur les points principaux
grâce à un meilleur travail en
commission l'évaluation des lois sera
plus systématique et pendant les
semaines de contrôler les parlementaires
pourront procéder aux corrections ou au
simplification des lois faisant l'objet
de l'évaluation
le vote du budget sera plus rapide 50
jours au lieu des 70 qui prévalent
aujourd'hui mais un temps plus long sera
dédiée chaque printemps à l'évaluation
des politiques publiques et au contrôle
de l'exécution du budget par les
ministres il s'agit là de corriger un
décalage propre à nos instituts à nos
institutions dans lequel nous consacrons
beaucoup de temps à la discussion du
budget initial et très peu de temps
aux conditions de contrôle et l'examen
de l'exécution réel de ce budget